Did you see the football game last night?
No, I missed it unfortunately,...
...but I heard it was an amazing game.
Was it ever!
The Seahawks were down by four touchdowns in the last quarter,...
...but came back to win it in overtime.
Sounds like a thriller! I bet the fans were going crazy.
The players said that they couldn't even hear themselves think on the field.
So what happened exactly?
Well, as I said, they were down by 28 points in the last quarter,...
...but they just got on a roll and tied the game on the final play.
Then it went into overtime?
Yeah, and they got a field goal to win it in the first few minutes.
Man, I'm sorry I missed it.
That'll teach you to work late on a Monday night!
I'll say!